and finally no you can't have any more
Republican candidates for president
until you tell me what you did with Rand
Paul who was last seen standing in front
of an aircraft carrier setting fire to
everything he used to believe and this
was just two days into his campaign the
Mayweather fight was boring but at least
it lasted 12 rounds the establishment
made Rand Paul its [ __ ] at the weigh-in
well you know I know it's the primary
season but Rand Paul was supposed to be
my Republican option the guy who could
stand on a debate stage with a dozen
pandering cookie cutter creeps and tell
a crowd what they didn't want to hear so
I got a queasy feeling a couple of weeks
ago when Senator Paul spoke at a prayer
breakfast red flag and totally jumped a
shark on gay marriage he'd always been
the libertarian guy on personal issues
live-and-let-live just don't get any on
me
now he says now he says we need another
Great Awakening with tent revivals of
thousands of people praying reform or
see what's going to happen if we don't
yes clearly this is how we steer America
toward the future with anti-gay tent
revivals behold the sodomite hurling her
prayers at him before he be released to
the children of the corn and then came
the aircraft carrier the next hint that
something was wrong because if you want
to say I'm a new kind of Republican
don't do it all the rest of them do and
stand in front of the Yorktown as if to
say ship strong be strong ship kill
foreigners we kill foreigners and then
suggest adding a hundred and ninety
billion dollars to the defense budget
the one you used to want to cut it's all
just proof that to be competitive
Republican candidates must say to their
base
to paraphrase Bill Clinton I feel you're
crazy
and that's no matter how crazy it is
have you heard of Jade helm 15 I know it
sounds like a sequel to the porn video
Jade helm 14 but it's actually the
codename for a routine training exercise
the US military is planning to conduct
in the southwest which the tea baggers
and Texas are convinced is actually an
Obama plot to invade Texas take their
guns and impose a new world order yes
because we hate Lubbock for its freedom
but here's the thing in today's
Republican Party you can't call out
nutty people for being nutty because
they're not a small group in the
Republican Party crazy is a constituency
so
so what happens is the governor of Texas
indulges them and says he will be
ordering the Texas State Guard to keep
an eye on the United States military
you know our former ally and Rand Paul
former sane person says Jade helm 15
yeah I'm going to look into that to look
into what whether Obama is planning to
invade Texas great while you're at it
could you please see if the Supreme
Court is run by lizard people okay one
last point you rural white people who
are always saying things like don't mess
with Texas we tell you something you are
among the most left alone least messed
with people on the planet you can carry
an assault rifle into Chile's what more
do you want the right to do it shirtless
you're practically your own independent
country now you've outlawed abortion
you've got a government regulation
you're armed to the teeth you're the
white Somalia
stop worrying about getting sucked into
the New World Order you're barely in the
current World Order and the only reason
we conduct military exercises in your
area is there's no chance of
accidentally damaging anything anybody
cares about
you